I don't know how we stumbled upon this
but I brought up Robin Vickers name last
hour and we were talking about the fans
in Houston who were heckling Kevin
Durant last night there was one fan who
kept yelling out chanting New York
Knicks whenever he would get at the
free-throw line
and social media picked up on this and
social media making you know a bigger
story out of this because we don't know
if Golden State and Kevin Durant are
gonna part ways and will he end up with
the Knicks and it took a lot longer you
know back in the 80s and 90s but if you
made it on SportsCenter and I remember
Robin Ficker who was one of the better
hecklers in all the sports and he was
there for the bullets they were the
bullets before the Wizards and Robin had
season tickets he went to every home
game I think he might have been in the
second row but the but the players knew
Robin and it was almost like a badge of
honor if Robin singled you out and
started heckling you you had to be good
I think for for Robin to be heckling you
an attorney political activist infamous
sports heckler one of the forefathers
Robin Thicke er joining us on the
program good morning Robin how are you
well good morning I would have mentioned
to Kevin Durant I would have mentioned
the name Monica Wright his ex fiance
who's getting married Mike Rogers and
Kevin's not even invited to the wedding
you know she tossed Kevin aside and
she's marrying some guy who played for
Valparaiso and Kevin I would have put
that in his mind to keep his thinking
away from what he was supposed to be
doing he's not even the most highly paid
player on on Golden State that curry
makes more money than he does even
though says Curry's dad was a poor shot
when when I used to sit behind him he
beat me he was a street shooter just
like sets us a little bit better than
his dad but neither one of them can
really do much else than sit behind a
three-point line and pop it in but Kevin
Durant I think we need to get into why
he's not being invited to the wedding of
the girl he was engaged to for so long
he really you know he still
it out with Seattle we played for
Oklahoma for about eight years and he's
been with Golden State for three so now
he's looking around again where's your
anchor Kevin why don't you stay in one
place and do well what I know you're
making more than 300 thousand each game
okay why don't you get your salary up
where a Seth Curry salary is up near the
top you've got a teammate earning more
than you you claim that you're so good
but why don't you just concentrate in
one area instead of moving around like a
jitterbug all right you haven't lost
your fastball give me give me a sense of
the players did did players read how
many players reacted to you they all did
they used to move their timeouts their
timeout Huddle's away from the bench I I
was in the front row and then they
passed the rule which is still printed
on the back of every season ticket which
says that that fans cannot sit behind
the opposing bench and interfere with
communication between the opposing coach
and players and if they do they shall be
given a warning if they're given two
warnings and they're tossed out of the
game but you know it's free speech if
they don't want the fans who really pay
all the royalties who buy the products
who make the game what it is if they
don't want the game next to those
players and perhaps they should put up a
barrier like they have in hockey you
know so the fan so the players these
sensitive little players who are earning
300 thousand again can hear what the
fans have to say these fans have worked
hard all week want to let loose who are
getting a vicarious thrill who want to
talk to these players if they don't want
to hear that they don't want the players
to hear what the fans are saying then
they should stop selling propinquity
they sell these seats right on the court
right next to the players the NBA is
making a lot of money from these fans
maybe they should make the recall the
players wear earplugs so that they don't
get their mind off their game I wasn't
heckling them I was just giving them
therapy is the Charles Barkley
story true did he fly you into Chicago
during the NBA Finals or buy your ticket
or to heckle Jordan no that was into
Phoenix in Phoenix when he played for
Phoenix Charles Barkley was he was
really my favorite player he used to
leave little notes on my seat saying Rob
and I hope you don't give me a hard time
tonight he gave me the game ball a few
times he brought down a huge a 76er
emblem which was on a ring it was about
ten feet across and they held that up
behind the 76 or bench so that the
players and Jim Lyman couldn't hear me
and then the league made him take it
down I would say to Charles Charles
I heard you're running for governor of
Alabama before I vote for you I want to
know your view on health care the
economy and nasta and he turned around
and said well I do have a view on the
death penalty they should use it on you
did Jordan ever respond to you oh yeah
he did because he had claimed he had
read Sam Smith's book the Jordan rules
he claimed he hadn't read it which was a
best-seller you read it to him didn't
you I read him because some of the
embarrassing excerpts where he made
comments about his his teammates calling
old one of the guys a six foot ten
stiffy he made some uncomplimentary
remarks they were uncomplimentary quotes
in the book and then occasionally I
would make things up and he would turn
around when I did and shake his head no
he'd read every word of that but he and
Charles were different because after the
game Charles would go out in the clubs
and there'd be people crowding around
Mike would go into his private dining
room and sit there with some friends was
there really two different people but of
course they're both wonderful athletes
did anybody take a swing at you um yeah
coach Frank Layden did not a lot of
reach there
Frank Layden I was complimenting him he
was having a feud with Adrian Dantley
who's one of his best players I was
mentioning that feud and I was also
bringing up the fact that USA Today had
graded him the worst-dressed coach in
the NBA okay so I was on him to hold the
whole game about Adrian and about how he
was dressed and what he should be
wearing to the games and at the end of
the game which they won he came he came
through the seat he started coming
through the seat the mailman was holding
him back Carl Malone was holding about
swinging spitting he completely lost it
and I was really everything I said could
have been printed in the paper nothing
was about sexual matters or about race
or about anything that or anything that
couldn't be said would you consider
coming back well it's a lot of fun
that's just I'm so busy now doing other
things you know I broke away from it
because my daughter was a professional
triathlete she was ended up second in
the world Ironman she was going all over
the world I broke away from it my sons
wrestled in college and so they were
there other things you can do other than
go to the NBA but believe me I didn't
miss a game for 12 years there was a lot
of fun while it lasted and I got to know
every player in the NBA
Chucky's remains my favorite because
he's very good with the rep party Shaq I
know was interviewed they asked him what
he remembered most about his first year
and the NBA he said I remembered that
guy behind the bench in Washington who
was giving me a hard time the whole game
even after I scored 20 points in the
first half I used to I used to I
listened to all his rap records where he
would say you know he's got skills and I
would change it to you've got bills and
I'd miss some of his bill he'd get a pig
he gets
they get upset the whole idea really was
just to take their mind off their game
you know Jimmy Jackson I used to call
him any action because he couldn't miss
a we had a lot of fun but but I'll tell
you part Hardin is looking good it's
uncanny the game has changed since I was
there because of these three-point shots
I've never seen anyone who can just
dribble like he does fake a guy out
almost the guy almost falls over and
then he sits back in his hits these
threes the threes have changed the game
totally yeah and you can argue if it's
changed it for the better or not Robin
it's great to catch up with you and
thanks for joining us and sharing some
stories yeah the best player I ever saw
quite frankly and I saw him in
Philadelphia when I was in law school
there was Wilt Chamberlain because no
one could stop that guy he would just
sit under there and dunk the basketball
he because he's a lot stronger than then
the guy from Milwaukee Bucks he was just
the tower of power I know you couldn't
stop him and I'm gonna have to try to
stop you Robin we're up against the
commercial break here Thank You Robin
we appreciate that some great stories
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on VR live or download the Dan
Patrick show at